if you go back and watch some of those
numerous debates
he was so bad he wasn't even coherent
and against bernie he was and we're
calling for a drug test
it's not all there everybody knows it i
like
running against people that are weak
mentally i think joe is the weakest up
here
now sleepy joe
go to joe 303
oh it's uh it's it's great to be here
and uh
back uh a little place where uh
you know uh we tried it in and iraq is
not working so now we're gonna try
i mean in iran excuse me we tried in
ukraine
i am very willing to let the american
public
judge my physical mental filter my
physical as well as my mental
fitness why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program you take
a test where you're taking cocaine or
not what do you think huh
[Music]
i hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the
investigation we've performed 1.87
million tests today so that's 1 million
000 million tests
person woman man
camera tv
you